[Music]
[Music]
welcome to nasa's
jet propulsion laboratory in southern
california
days ago nasa's most sophisticated and
capable rover to date
landed on mars the perseverance rover
today we'll see mars like never before
with new photos and videos
our panel today will help us understand
how perseverance captured what it's like
to land on mars
and what the landing site looks like i'm
your host raquel villanueva
and joining us is matt wallace
perseverance deputy project manager
dave grull perseverance entry descent
and landing camera suite lead
al chen perseverance entry descent and
landing lead
justin mackey perseverance imaging
scientist
and instrument operations team chief
jessica samuels perseverance surface
mission
manager ken williford perseverance
deputy project scientist and to tell us
what this
all means for nasa and exploration
thomas zurbukin associate administrator
for
nasa's science mission directorate
we will take questions during this
briefing if you're a member of the media
on the phone lines
press star one to be put in the queue if
you're on social media
use the hashtag countdown to mars
now to get us started is jpl director
mike watkins now i will step aside for
him to give his opening remarks
thank you welcome back to jpl we have a
jam-packed
press conference today and i was just
looking at uh at the team here i think
we're trying to add it up maybe a
hundred years of combined experience
with mars rovers on the panel today now
we
have been working very hard since we
landed the surface team has been getting
the rover
set up for the surface mission they've
been working mars time
over the weekend making fantastic
progress and you'll hear about that
today
you'll also see some brand new images
and videos that we acquired over the
weekend
are downlinked over the weekend and
these are really fantastic images of the
surface of mars
and the rest of the descent imagery that
that we got a preview of
on friday these images
have always been part of the history of
jpl we have taken
everyone along with us on our journeys
across the solar system
through the rings of saturn looking back
at the pale blue dot
and incredible panoramas on the surface
of mars
this is the first time we've been able
to actually capture
an event like the landing of a
spacecraft on mars
and these are pretty cool videos and we
will learn something
by looking at the performance of the
vehicle in these videos but a lot of it
is also
to bring you along uh on our journey our
touchdown to mars and of course
our surface mission as well and these
are really amazing videos
we all binge watched them over the
weekend if you can
call a one minute video binge watching
but
but we watched it many many times and
it's really fantastic
and just to show you how far we've come
in history of jpl
i want to show one image this is from
mariner 4
in 1965. so this was actually
the first data first images sent back
from mars by mariner 4
and that was hand colored by the
engineers according to a code
kind of like a paint by numbers uh
painting
and that's there it is the first color
color image hand painted
and so when you see these videos later
uh i i think dave grohl and justin
mackey will be overjoyed that they
didn't
have to hand color each one of these
each one of these images
so my hat is off it's a great press
conference today my head is off to the
team uh you know for getting
the rover to where we are and these
fantastic images down
and to learn more about that team let me
introduce matt wallace
thanks very much mike and thanks for the
nice words about the uh
the the team i'll try to be brief
because i want to get to this video and
i know you do too
um i just want to give you a little bit
of background on how this whole thing
started
my daughter is a gymnast she's been a
gymnast since she was
a little kid and when she was about
i guess 11 years old and the project was
still in formulation
she asked me for one of those little
sports cameras
and being the indulgent parent i am i i
got her the sports camera
and she put it in the harness that it
came with and she put the harness on
and she did a backflip and uh
i i don't know about you but i cannot do
a backflip but when she showed me the
video
and i watched that camera pan up to the
ceiling
and then the room go upside down
and then somehow write itself as she
landed on her feet
you know i felt for a moment
that i had a glimpse into what it would
be like if i
could do a backflip and uh that was the
moment that inspired
a phone call to my friend dave gruel
over here
and that's what led to this system
this entry descent and landing camera
system we call them the edl cams
that you're about to see the product of
here
just just in a moment
now i don't know about you but
uh it is unlikely at this point my
career that i will
pilot a spacecraft down to the surface
of mars
um but when you see this
imagery uh i think you will feel like
you are getting a glimpse into what it
would be like
to land successfully in jezreel cradle
crater with perseverance and so
without any further delay i'm going to
turn it over to dave he'll describe the
system
and we'll get to the video thanks great
thanks matt
um the idea of adding a
off ruggedized commercial hardware onto
a flagship spacecraft
to do a nice to have function proved to
be quite an interesting challenge that
matt handed over to us
along the way we encountered one maybe
two
people who were a little bit skeptical
of what we were trying to do
but thankfully we had the full support
of project leadership
all the individuals directly supporting
the 2020
mission were super excited to help and
in the end we were able to
actually make it happen
our edl camp team were guided by uh
two two requirements if you will the
first one was that the entry descent and
landing system
camera system must do no harm to the
flight vehicle
and that's especially important during
edl this was our one critical
requirement
and as you all saw last thursday uh that
requirement was met
the second item is not so much as a of a
requirement as it is
a mantra if you will uh we get what we
get
and we don't get upset um we wanted our
edl cam system to get onto the vehicle
and return amazing imagery
of the vehicle landing in jezreel crater
on mars like every other element
on the mars 2020 spacecraft individuals
worked really hard and went above and
beyond to make sure that their piece of
the spacecraft
did what it was supposed to do and would
be successful
but in the end we knew that our entry
descent and landing
camera system the mission could still be
100
successful if our camera system didn't
work
and if we could even get just one image
or one piece of information
back during edl that we shouldn't get
upset and we should be excited
um so as you probably realize after last
friday's press conference
um the ddo cam system
successfully captured some amazing
imagery of the vehicle's descent and
landing on the surface of mars
we collected a little over 30 gigabytes
of information
and over 23 000 images of the vehicle
descending down to the surface of mars
as a quick introduction if i could have
the first graphic or reminder for some
of you
exactly what are the sensors that we
included in the entry descent
and landing camera system there are
three cameras that are located on the
top of the vehicle
on the back shell those cameras actually
capture a high rate
75 frames a second imagery of the
parachute
inflating in the martian atmosphere now
one of the cameras
stopped operating coincident with the
mortar fire when the parachute was
deployed
and that's to be expected it is a very
high dynamic environment
but luckily the other two cameras
continue to operate as expected and
captured some amazing
footage of the parachutes inflating in
that martian atmosphere
we put one camera on the bottom of the
descent stage
that camera looked down on the rover as
we lowered the rover on the bridles
the mobility system latched into
position
and then the vehicle touched down onto
the surface of mars
we also installed two cameras onto the
rover
one on the top of the vehicle looking up
on the descent stage so the rover could
actually
see the descent stage lower it down to
the surface
and then ideally fly off into the
distance
after it had delivered perseverance
safely under the surface
and then we also put a camera on the
bottom of the rover which actually
looked down on the surface of mars once
the heat shield was dropped away
and that camera continued to capture
imagery until the vehicle touched down
on the surface of mars and then we also
put a microphone
on the port side of the rover now
unfortunately
i do have to say that we did not collect
any audio during
edl but uh please stay tuned a little
bit later
in this press conference because we do
have some exciting information about the
uh the edl cam microphone
so now the reaction to the edlcam videos
has been absolutely amazing
around jpl and uh we are super excited
to actually share with all of you video
imagery of perseverance landing on the
surface of mars
please roll the video starting the
straighten up and fly right maneuver
where the spacecraft will jettison the
entry balance masses
in preparation for parachute deploy and
to roll over to give the radar
a better look at the ground
complicated indicate shoot deploy
the navigation has confirmed that the
parachute has deployed and we are seeing
significant deceleration
in the velocity our current velocity is
450 meters per second at an altitude of
about 12 kilometers from the surface of
mars
heat shield set perseverance is now
slowed to subsonic
speeds and the heat shield has been
separated this allows
both the radar and the cameras to get
their first look at the surface
current velocity is 145 meters per
second and an altitude of about
10 km nine and a half kilometers above
the surface
now filter converge velocity solution
3.3 meters per second
altitude 7.4 kilometers now has radar
lock on the ground
current velocity is about 100 meters per
second
6.6 kilometers of the surface
perseverance is continuing to descend on
the parachute
we are coming up on the initialization
of terrain relative navigation
and subsequently the priming of the
landing engines our current velocity
is about 90 meters per second at an
altitude
of 4.2 kilometers
ovf salad we have confirmation that the
lander vision system has produced a
valid solution
and part of terrain relative navigation
priming
pba is nominal we have timing of the
landing engines
back shell set current velocity is 83
meters per second at about 2.6
kilometers from the surface mars
we have confirmation that the back shell
has separated
we are currently performing the divert
maneuver current velocity is about 75
meters per second at an altitude
of about a kilometer off the surface of
mars
here in safety bravo we have completed
our terrain relative navigation
current speed is about 30 meters per
second altitude of about 300 meters
off the surface of mars
we have started our constant velocity
accordion which means we are
conducting the sky crane about to
conduct the fly crane maneuver
skyteam maneuver has started
about 20 meters off the surface
we're getting signals from mro
tango delta touchdown confirmed
perseverance
faithfully on the surface of mars ready
to begin seeking the sand
of past life
it gives me goof bumps every time i i
see it just just amazing
i hope everybody kept their uh hands and
arms inside the vehicle at all times
while i was in motion
um so i do need to say uh i wouldn't be
sitting at this podium and you wouldn't
have all seen that uh
amazing imagery without a
a lot of support from amazing team both
those who worked directly on the edl cam
task as well as those who supported us
across the project i thank you for
everything you've done to get us here
today uh just an amazing amazing
accomplishment so
um i'm gonna turn over to al al is gonna
be our color analyst
it doesn't have an illustrator but he's
gonna actually walk through some of
those videos in even more detail
and actually show you some just
incredible things that you can actually
see once you look at those videos
over and over i'm not sure the color
commentator is supposed to have as many
chills as i do right now and every time
i see these videos
but i want to add my thanks to the uh to
el camera team i mean these videos and
these images
are the stuff of our dreams it's been
the what we've been dreaming about for
years
so thank you so much um
let's see uh as uh as dave mentioned
we'll try to walk through what we see a
little bit
we won't take that much time because uh
we could spend literally all day looking
at these videos and some of us have
spent all the weekend looking at these
videos but we'll just try to show you
some highlights of
what we've been seeing and invite you
all to continue to look for more things
as we kind of see new things every time
we look at these videos
so let's start with the parachute upload
camera and let me give you a quick
warning to not blink
because things go really fast here
you can see that you can get a sense
really of how violent that parachute
deploy and inflation are
the parachute pack it's the parachute is
packed so densely that the
pack is basically the same density as
oak and it's about 150 pounds
it gets launched out of the spacecraft
with a mortar which is basically a
cannon
with a muzzle velocity of around 100
miles an hour and the spacecraft itself
was going about a thousand miles an hour
at this point
going about 1.75 times the speed of
sound so just in case you blink let's
show you that one more time
you kind of see that in high speed and
then or real time and then we'll slow it
down
and take a look at the details okay
so let's try to walk through this a bit
slower this time at about quarter speed
and we'll pause at times to point out
things we see
so let's start that rolling
here you can see the pack getting pushed
out of there now you can kind of see the
pack right in the middle
as it's being pushed and the parachute
lid which is right on top of it it's
kind of that circle to the left of the
pack
was on top of the pack and it was it was
there to protect the parachute during
entry it's got some thermal protection
system material on it
to keep the parachute nice and cool and
protected and the pack is used to push
that lid right off the vehicle
given that cannon force you can also see
some of the other things that have
popped off of that lid
which is kind of expected given how
violent this uh this launch really is
so let's move on from here
so we keep going out here you can see
the pack reach what we call line stretch
so that's as far as it's going to go
it's
where the parachute is going to start
inflating that's about 150 feet behind
the spacecraft and it got there in just
under one second so this pack is really
moving
that's pretty much as the parachute
starts to come out you can see the pack
is rotated about 90 degrees that's
pretty common
we've seen that in some of our testing
here on earth at high altitude as well
so let's keep going and take a look at
the inflation
side inflation really looks textbook
it's nice and symmetric
the parachute opens in only about seven
tenths of a second again really fast
there's no evidence of tangling of the
lines which is great um that's uh
there's about two miles of lines in the
parachute system
so the fact that we don't see any
evidence of tangling or any kind of
other misbehavior
is great news and i'm sure we'll be
studying this video for many many years
and
picking it apart frame by frame and of
course we have a second
camera on board as well that recorded
this this launch and inflation of the
parachute
you might notice the pattern that's on
the the parachute here
the sync patterns are useful in helping
us determine the clocking or orientation
of the parachute
also the contrasting sections can be
useful in tracking different positions
of the parachute different portions of
the parachute as it inflates
so it's especially useful when we have
multiple cameras as we do here and
trying to track features in the
parachute inflating in addition to
enabling incredible science
we hope our efforts and our engineering
can inspire others
sometimes we leave messages in our work
for others to find for that purpose
so we invite you all to give it a shot
and show your work
let's move on to the rover download
camera and take a look at that in a
little bit more detail
so if we start that up you can see the
heat shield falling away very nicely and
symmetrically
pausing here we can take a look at what
we see on the on the heat shield
first we see the medley components on
the heat shield you can see the
electronics box and the gold wires that
lead to all the various
to all the various sensors that measure
the aerodynamics and heating
during entry during the entry portion of
flight we can also see some white flecks
in different places both on the heat
shield and free flying which are likely
frost that accumulated on the heat
shield
that heat shield is really really cold
during cruise so it's not at all
unexpected to see some of that frost
appearing on the heat shield
on the inside you can also see something
we didn't expect to see if you kind of
look at the
four o'clock position on the heat shield
or so
towards the middle somewhere somewhere
between the middle and the edge
one of the springs that helped push the
heat shield off seems to have come loose
it doesn't you know it's not much of a
big deal but it's definitely uh
not not what we expected if you look at
the other eight
springs they actually are where they're
supposed to be all around the edge of
the heat shield
there's no danger to the spacecraft here
but it's something we
expect and i think we wouldn't see if we
didn't have the camera system to show us
what was going on
so let's keep rolling here we can see
that the heat shield basically stays in
the same orientation
as it flies away from us they'll come
back into view in a little bit
but this is uh this is great this is
kind of what we expected in terms of the
aerodynamics of that heat shield it
doesn't tumble or do something
weird uh that was unexpected in flight
so that's very useful to have this video
to show us that
um so in the interest of time let's skip
ahead uh to about 15 seconds before
backshell separation
so starting this video here you can see
that the spacecraft is rocking back and
forth
while hanging under the parachute this
this rocky is less than it was earlier
in flight but
pretty much what we expect there that
white flash was backshell separation
and you can see us throttle up and begin
our divert maneuver you see the vehicles
turned over so we're actually beginning
to fly
east and that's why you can see the the
delta over there
as it as it maneuvers eastward to the
eventual landing site it actually passes
over the field of view will pass over
the landing site and then kind of
overshoot it a little bit
because it's got to stop that horizontal
divert that we did
you can see everything's nice and smooth
now that the engines are under control
that on-sheet parachute rocking is gone
so here we are slowing down and stopping
and we're coming straight down on our
eventual landing site here
you can see that as we as we're really
going to slow down here you can see the
engines as we get lower
throttle up there and and stop us here
you can see it beginning to push all
that dust around on the ground
on the two sides that shaking there is
the rover deploying and the mobility
during sky crane
and here we are coming down and that
that rocking motion of the
of the rover we'll see in other videos
but that settles down right before we
hit the ground in a nice
safe flat spot there doesn't appear to
be too much of concern that's right
below us
so that was the rover's view looking
down let's take a look at the descent
stage view
uh looking down as well uh during that
skycrane portion of flight
so here we go the rover begins to drop
away from the descent stage and that's
the first
the first part of mobility deployed you
can kind of see here right before we
pause that the
mobility kind of shook a little bit in
that in that first deployment
here you can see the the bridles that
are hanging down from the top of the
picture those are what's supporting the
weight of the rover below the descent
stage
and if you look down toward the left the
bottom part of the image and toward the
left
you can see that gold unbubble that's uh
what's transferring all the information
between the rover and the descent stage
including this video uh this picture is
coming down uh from the camera up on the
descent stage down to the rover through
that cord
in addition to other information that's
going back and forth
um so as we keep going here you can see
the bogey
that's on both sides of the mobility
back you see those wheels the back two
wheels on either side swing down
that caused a little bit of rocking of
the rover as expected but you can kind
of see that kind of settles out a little
bit
right as we enter that that uh that
plume and dust cloud
as we get down and touch down and the
video ends a touchdown of course because
the camera that's taking this video
is about to leave this area in a hurry
on that descent stage after we
we cut it loose from the rover so now
let's take a look at the
rover upload camera so now staring up at
the at the descent stage from the rover
so here we go we got a really close up
look at the descent stage and we can
start rolling that
you can see the descent stage as the
rover begins to fall away from it and
see the effect of that rover wobble from
the mobility deploy
so pausing here the first thing that
most people will probably notice is that
there's no
no plumes or no visible smoke or
anything else coming out of the rockets
at the corner of the descent that's
expected hydrazine doesn't really
isn't isn't a combustion reaction when
we when we burn it
the exhaust products are nitrogen and
hydrogen which are clear
so we expect the the plumes to be clear
that's what we see in tests here on
earth as well
so i can promise you those engines are
on though uh one thing you can see in
this
in the earth testing we do is that the
chambers the thrust chambers of those
engines get kind of hot
and glow pink and you can kind of see
that in the interior especially if you
look at the
the the engine at the very top right of
this image
if you look closely right above the uh
the engine bell there on the truss
chamber
you can see little streaks of pink on
there and that's what's happening
as the engines have been on for a long
time they get really hot
and that heat shows up there in those
pink stripes that we see
so take a look at that closely when you
get a chance to look at the image in
some detail
as with the previous videos you can see
the bridles that are supporting the
weight of the rover there at the bottom
now of this image
and that umbilical again transferring uh
transferring data back and forth between
the
stage and the rover so let's keep going
a little bit more
you'll see the image begin to wobble a
little bit here i can promise not the
descent stage wobbling
it's actually that rover tipping back
and forth a little bit as we saw
as the mobility deploys both the first
initial mobility deploy
and then the the the bogeys deploying
as we near touchdown let's slow it down
a bit and proceed in slow-mo here
so now we're watching about quarter
speed things are getting pretty dusty
here as we get down
down toward the bottom take a look here
at the bottom left of this picture
you'll see actually the instant that we
cut the descent stage away
and you'll see those begin to get
retracted up toward that descent stage
as they're pulled up and this is as
planned
see as they got yanked up there uh right
before and then we'll see the
descent stage begin to turn and ascend
and head out uh toward the northwest
with the
umbilical dangling behind it
since the rover was pointed almost
directly to southeast the descent stage
chose
to go toward the back that's also to
make sure of course that the
the engines don't plume the rover that
we don't damage the rover
with those that engine thrust so we sent
that descent stage
off to the northwest which uh jessica
will show you about in a little bit
so i can and have watched those videos
for hours and keep seeing new stuff
every time
so i invite you all to do that too so
now i'll turn it over to justin who will
talk to you a little bit about the
images we've been taking on the ground
all right thank you al i'm justin mackey
i'm
the mars 2020 perseverance imaging
scientist here
and i developed imaging systems at jpl
and uh when
when dave asked me to help out with the
edl cam development about
six years ago we were
i was really excited about it and it
would be challenging and interesting
and even possibly spectacular but i had
no idea that it would be this amazing
and we are
so happy and proud and i just want to
thank dave and
matt for just giving us the leadership
and
giving us the chance to do this um like
matt and dave and jennifer and rick
and others on the project i've i've
actually worked on all five of the nasa
revolutions and as
part of my job i review images from mars
like every day that's what i do and when
i saw these
images come down um i have to say i was
truly amazed
um i know it's been a tough year um for
everybody and uh we're hoping that maybe
these images will
you know help brighten people's day um
you know your
smartphones and make them your your
screen backgrounds and things i'm just
really happy that it all worked out so
so now we're on mars and i'm going to
talk a little bit about what we've been
doing
over the weekend um over the weekend
we deployed the rsm if you go to the
first picture there's a picture of the
remote sensing mask the rsm which is
that mast on the rover and you can see
the navigation cameras up there the left
and right navigation cameras or nav cams
as we call them
this is another new imaging system that
we've developed
here specifically for the 2020 mission
these cameras represent a pretty
significant advancement over
previous imaging systems that we've
flown these are 20 megapixel
color cameras with very high resolution
and wide-angle
lenses that we use to basically map out
the surface as the river drives and then
we use these images to do planning and
things
and so we um the first thing we did
after we deployed the mass is we started
imaging the surface so the next slide
shows one of our first images from the
cameras
this image is actually in low resolution
mode
so it's one quarter of the full
resolution of the of the camera so it's
been it's been shrunk down
but you can see right there the vista
that we're seeing this is uh the rover
obviously on mars and you can see some
of the material that landed on the deck
but everything looks in good shape and
so we're using these images to inspect
not only the vehicle but the surface
around us the next slide shows the view
down towards the surface you can see the
wheels there
this is the same surface you just saw in
the edl cam videos
you could see some of the scouring that
the rocket plumes did for us clean it
off make it nice and clean so we can
take pictures of it and dust it off for
us
the next slide shows a view looking out
towards the south and this just an
amazing scene here uh this is it this is
mars where
we're here in our place that we're going
to be exploring over the next
months and coming years and it's just
really exciting to see
um you know these scenes look familiar
to us you know they look earth-like in a
sense you know you see them
the mountains back there and the rocks
and things it just
really is the surface of an alien world
and we just arrived
you can also see some more scouring
there over on the right
the next image looks over towards the
west you can see the delta
out there in the horizon and again more
scouring from the
rocket plumes and then we take all of
these images
and we stitch them together into
panoramas and so that next
the next frame shows the full panorama
from the nav cam
stitched together we're still working
out the calibration of things so this is
uh you know approximate color but it
just gives you a feel for
the vista here that we we're our new
environment that we're going to explore
and we're hoping everyone will join us
in
seeing these images we're uh today we're
going to be releasing
a whole slew of raw images it's been a
fire hose of data basically we have
thousands of images already from the edl
cameras
nav cams uh you've seen the haz cams and
so we will be putting those uh out on
the website today uh for people to
download and
uh process yourself or just look at the
great picture
find your favorite picture and uh make
it make it your screen background
and and then the last um image that i
just wanted to point out is the
first image one of the first images from
the mastcam z camera this is another
next generation imaging system on the
rover
jim bell is the the pi i'm the deputy pi
for this
working with our industry partners ms
cubed down in san diego um
this is just a fantastic imaging system
this is a preview of things to come
this system has a zoom lens on it that's
what the z stands for
uh and we're going to get incredibly
high resolution photos
from this imaging system i just wanted
to point out a few things in this
picture
on the far right you can see those
cables uh
they had been cut uh in the video that
you just saw so there's kind of a
close-up of that
and then just in the middle to the left
of that that black
instrument that that's uh the rover
upload camera that's the camera that
actually took the video of the sky crane
as as we were coming down and then in
the bottom of the frame is the mass cam
z calibration target
set there's two of them there's the
circular one with the the shadow post
and then the color
chips down the bottom there's another
cal target in the back that's the super
cam instrument
with our partners from los alamos and in
france
we're going to be commissioning super
cam over the next few days
and then finally just as a teaser i'll
point out that there is a little antenna
there to the right
on that uh box in the center right that
is the helicopter antenna it's a
helicopter base station location
and a preview of things to come we're
excited about that as well
so with that i'm going to turn it over
to jessica to talk about latest status
all right thank you justin i know you
can
test firsthand to being in the control
room and the excitement that
everybody has been experiencing seeing
all these images from the surface
and as they come down you know we're
immediately
sharing them and everybody clapping and
smiles all around
great camera suite so i am happy to
report
that perseverance is healthy and
continuing with activities as we have
been
planning them over the first few sols on
the surface
to date which is really only just you
know three solves of activities and one
more
and coming up later this afternoon we've
commanded 5000 we've executed 5 000
commands
so lots of uh instructions to the
vehicle for
for her to perform and having everything
come back exactly how we've been wanting
it to
um with respect to our health checkouts
and um our instrument uh
checkout so that's been things have been
going well a couple of
key highlights so we have fired and
replete and released
our launch lock restraints to allow our
mechanisms
to be deployed we saw the remote sensing
mast
but one of those also being the high
gain antenna
now this is important for the high gain
antenna to be deployed because it
increases
our uplink rate um to the rover and so
it will
allow us to send a higher
volume of instructions uh to
perseverance and allow her to perform
more involved activities over the days
to come
additionally with respect to our
communication
we have established a strong
communication link
with all of our relay orbiters and
our partners the mars reconnaissance
orbiter
the maven orbiter trace gas observer the
tgo and odyssey spacecraft and so
we thank those teams and are happy to be
able to use those
assets to relay all of the information
that we
all these beautiful images that we are
looking at today
the remote sensing mesh remote sensing
mast motion checks were nominal and as
expected
and all of our instruments have gone
through their initial checkouts
and we're happy to report that they are
all performing
nominally and as expected now when i say
nominal it really means
fantastic because uh we can't
wait to continue to use this payload
suite
our backup computer was turned on
yesterday
and that was in preparation for
our upcoming flight software transition
which we will be performing
over the next few days and the ingenuity
helicopter
has also been checked out
we have performed a battery charging
event which we will continue to perform
over the weeks to come in preparation
for that aspect of the mission
but looking ahead we are excited to be
par
to be on our surface flight software
is a much more uh surface capable give a
lot more capabilities for the surface
mission as part of this fight software
load
it will take us a few days to transition
but once we're on that load it will
allow us to do further in-depth
checkouts of the instrument
as well as deploy the robotic arm
and exercise some of the turret
items that you see in this image so you
can see that we have our coring drill in
the center
our pixel and sherlock instruments
mounted to the side
and that black tank is to support the
gut the
gas dust removal tool which will
remove uh dust from the surfaces that we
will be inspecting later
so uh coming up here the uh the wheels
uh if you noticed in the image now are
off to the side we will be performing a
wiggle
we'll straighten those up we'll do a
short drive
uh and as i mentioned deploy the robotic
arm
and then continue with further in-depth
checkouts
so we are very excited to be happily on
the surface
and uh and exercising our system
and looking for what's ahead
so going back to our partnership with
the larger mars
um spacecraft and science teams and
community we're really excited
that the mro spacecraft mars
reconnaissance orbiter
and the highrise uh team was able
to find our hardware on the surface of
mars so if you see in this image
if the next pop-up you can see that we
have the descent stage
the parachute and the heat shield all
here
in this image with a few stats here the
descent stage is about 700 meters
away from where perseverance is on the
surface
parachute is about 1.2 kilometers and
the heat shield about 1.5 kilometers
and so it's a very exciting that we can
see all these
different components now that we've
landed on the surface
and as a special treat uh the highrise
image was able to actually acquire
um the entry descent landing event from
their perspective
and uh we can never have
enough images of this activity and so
this is a fantastic view
but i'm going to send it back to dave
here he uh
as part of this suite we have one more
surprise or one more
uh gift i'll say um that uh that we've
been able to
um receive from this package over here
dave
thanks jessica so i think we probably
have overloaded your visual sense for a
little bit
we're gonna do something a little bit
different and i'm gonna have some fun
here for a second too so i'm going to
get rid of this
and i'm going to talk to you now with
this this
is the microphone that was part of the
edl camera
system um when the edl cam system was
first envisioned it was set up as
just a bunch of cameras um to capture
some amazing imagery on the surface of
mars
and about a year or so after it was
first conceived i got a phone call
another call from matt
after talking to headquarters asked the
question could we possibly put a
microphone as part of our edl camera
system so we work with the team we took
a look
and uh sure enough it was something that
we could do and so we started off that
detail design
and uh identifying a microphone that
would work for us and uh getting it onto
the vehicle
about a year after uh this first started
i'm giving a tour um at jpl
and i happened to mention to the group
that i was giving the tour to
that the decision had come down and we
were working to actually include a
microphone
onto onto the vehicle and after the tour
was done
a gal came up to me and she said some
things to me that i won't forget
anytime soon she said i'm super excited
that you guys are going to try to put a
microphone
onto the rover and get it to the surface
of mars and and i was very appreciative
and i asked her afterwards i said
i'm curious why is it that this relates
to you so much
and her response was that her sister was
visually impaired
she was not able to see these images
that uh
that we saw earlier or that we sent down
in the past
and while she tries to describe them to
her she felt that she just
can't quite capture that same sense of
amazement that she gets when she gets
individually
and that by actually getting a
microphone at the surface of mars
the hope was that she'd be able to
experience things on mars
the same way that uh that she was when
she actually looked at them
and that stuck with me we continued to
work super hard to make sure that this
microphone would work
and that's part of the reason we were
disappointed why it didn't work when we
actually went and did
our entry descent lending sequence um i
wish i had actually captured
that individual's name i would love to
reach out to her now
and say we've done it i hope your sister
is enjoying it
because what i'm going to show you in a
second or what i'm going to you're going
to hear in a second
is actually the first sounds being
recorded from the surface of mars so
there are two microphones on the
perseverance vehicle
there's this microphone here part of the
entry descent and landing system and
there's a second microphone that is on
the supercam instrument
and we're we're counting on both these
instruments recording some
absolutely amazing uh sounds from
the surface of mars so with that um i
invite you now to if you would like to
close your eyes
and just imagine yourself sitting on the
surface of mars and listening to
to the surroundings if i could have the
first one please
so that gentle world that happens in the
background that is a noise made by the
rover
but yes what you did here 10 seconds in
was an actual wind gust on the surface
of mars
picked up by the microphone and sent
back to us here on earth
the analysis indicates that was around a
5 meter per second type of wind gust
so we have actually we can sit here now
and actually tell you that we have
recorded sound
from the surface of mars so we have a
second one
which basically further reduces the
noise of the rover
so you can just hear what the wind would
sound like on mars and once again
i invite you to sit back and have a
listen to what it would sound like to be
on mars
that's just it's cool it's really neat
overwhelming if you will um
i can't remember what i was going to go
and say next
um so looking forward to doing some
amazing things with the microphones
going forward we need to work with the
ops team there's some great science that
they're they're looking to do we're
hopeful that we continue to use these
microphones both the super cam
microphone and the edl cam microphone
to capture sounds perhaps the rocks
interacting with the surface
supercam is going to use theirs to get
some great data of them zapping rocks
so as you've heard and we'll continue
here we're just beginning to do amazing
things on the surface of mars
and now ken is going to talk to you a
little bit about the science that we've
done to date and what they're looking
forward to doing as we continue to move
forward
thanks dave and i'll start by just
taking this opportunity to say to matt
dave al and everybody else on this
fantastic team
thank you for the ride of a lifetime
that
is just incredible what we've seen today
and and what i'm sure
we'll continue to see as the mission
unfolds
so with all the focus on these uh
spectacular videos and
audio we wanted to make sure to remind
you that there is plenty of science
going on
already with hundreds of team members
poring over every new
image so if we can get the first of
those
images as you'll see in this navcam
frame
we start with what may seem like very
basic observations
light rocks dark rocks holy rocks
that's holy with an e we use these very
generic terms at this early stage
until we have more data that allow us to
test our hypotheses
and make more confident interpretations
follow along with the mission and you'll
see this is a theme
as we get closer our view of mars
continues to resolve
and a coherent story emerges
next image please
finally i just want to briefly point out
that we are finding real science value
in these edl cam videos here you can see
a beautiful new perspective on the
jezero delta
and if we can get the next image
also a new perspective on some of the
beautiful stratigraphy around our
landing site which is
is up near uh on the far right side of
this image
uh so now to put all of this in context
for us i'll hand it over to dr
thomas zurbukin
well what we've seen here today is
really nothing
short of amazing you know and i perhaps
you've had moments like this before
some of you have told me that i was
too young to remember but they had a
moment like that for example when they
observed
the first landing on the moon they had
moments like that where it felt
that we took a big leap a big leap not
just
in this case because of at jpl or at
nasa but at big loop
as humanity uh of course
it's a leap that was enabled by work
over decades and on this mission for
close to a decade
so what's possible there or it feels
possible is different
even yesterday it's how it
feels to make history and i just that's
how i feel today i'm so moved by this
wow
the video of perseverance is sand and
land
the amazing panorama and the first white
landscape shot of chesric
seen with human eyes and the first
martian sounds
are the closest you can get to landing
on mars without putting on a pressure
suit that video i believe
should become mandatory view for young
people
who not only want to explore other world
and build spacecraft to take them there
but also want to be part of diverse
teams achieving all the audacious goals
of our future
at the center of that is a team and i'll
ask for the next image
now you should know i met this team i
see me there in a dark suit
next to uh dr laurie glaze the body
division director and now he just uh he
just talked to you is
on his knee and there and the android
ascendant landing team and we met him
just hours before that historic landing
and i love this picture because of
course
the event today demonstrates that the
human aspect of exploration
and that is of course every reason for
what we can do
at nasa and also why we do things
the video audio images here are
provided to us are from the surface
of mars and sometimes we forget if we
look at that
well the robot shouldn't get all the fun
we want to make sure that all
of us on earth see and feel what it's
like
to be on our mars and explore other
worlds
i'm so excited for the more than one
million students who join
the mars student challenge and the many
more across the world
will be inspired by these images
released today and even yesterday
their journey is also just the beginning
just imagine
imagine perseverance sitting on a hill
recording the next martian landing
with a cargo that is basically a rocket
and then the
first from another world with samples
bound
for earth that are collected by
perseverance now in the near future
imagine follow the entry descendant of
the first human crew
on the planetary surface sometimes in
the future
this future historical way which i'm
confident
will happen will be enabled by women and
men
working in diverse teams
imagine the goals we can achieve
together so what is possible
sometimes to address that question it's
good to look back and think where we've
come from just like my friend mike did
earlier
we've been on a journey both as a human
race for
for quite a while now and i don't want
to show this next image of
sojourner of the pathfinder mission
uh which was designed for seven souls or
martian
days or so maybe 30 ultimately lasted
for 85
earth days in 1997. i
remember that really this thing clear
through pathfinder instead
in indeed that you know weighed 23
pounds and
i returned a surprising amount of
data back to earth and i'm try a
surprising amount of science for many
scientists i must say
some people didn't expect quite that
much and that's what happened sometimes
too
when you were in a white bait just like
we've seen here
we've grown from that sea that
perseverance is the size of a small car
and it's
ready for us for the next shine leaves
and here's a picture
that uh we're putting up that is one of
the many pictures that
we're releasing and of course it's a
picture one of my
absolute favorite and that's a picture
of the sample caching system on there
because it's that
sample caching system that will connect
this mission
to the samples that will bring back to
earth
and other historic feed we're working on
this system is on the surface of mars
now i remember this
by looking at it before we packed it up
from jpl and moved it over
then of course uh launched it from
from the top of a rocket that's my
friends it's one of the
indelible moments in nasa's history what
we can see
and what we can learn and what we can
hope for in the future and the
extraordinary emotions that takes
makes us feel all of us coming together
that human element will fill our future
at mars which is bright indeed
and it will fuel the dreams of a new
generation
that will return to mars and also study
the samples
that we will eventually bring home i'm
so grateful
to this team and literally that
thousands both at jpl and within the us
and around the world
to all of you who have engaged in this
mission
as has been noted the raw image pipeline
is opening up please go take a look at
these data and play with them especially
those of you
uh the children and the youth that have
signed up to our educational campaign
what can you find in these pictures and
who's going to compose the first piece
of music with actual mars
sound mike matt jennifer al
many of you leaders and could not be
more proud of both you
and your team on behalf of our entire
nasa leadership team
a heartfelt and a proud thanks to you
for the record matt i'm so glad for your
idea
about these cameras we will learn a lot
from that
much more than we ever expected and of
course this is just
a start for the surface team a real work
starts now to evaluate the surrounding
and start a plan and our trajectory
across chessroad crater
it's a big team and there are lots of
discussions but that's science in action
stay with us there is much more
amazement to come back to you raquel
thank you thomas and we'll now move on
to your questions
remember if you are a member of the
media on the phone line you can press
star one to get into the queue if you're
on social media you can tag questions
with the hashtag
countdown to mars now starting on the
phone line is bill harwood from
cbs news
yeah hi um i guess it's a pharrell or
maybe for matt
i mean other than the the loose spring
you guys saw on the heat shield is there
anything at all in that video that
looked off nominal i mean
you know it looked like it was almost
textbook um
and i'm not saying that just to i don't
know
give you free praise but i didn't see
you know i don't see anything like that
so is there anything thanks
so we've been i can take that when uh
we've been pouring over those videos and
looking for anything that
uh that could be wrong and also looking
at the rest of the data and we did have
a pretty clean run uh
through through entry descent and
landing there were a couple of bits of
the uh
pair of the parachute lid that came off
some of that was expected in fact we
knew that there was some risk
of that as well and there was if you
look at the video you can actually see a
chunk
that's the uh the radome it's a uh a
cover
for one of the uh pair that one of the
logan antennas we use during cruise and
also during part of edl
that came off we had hoped that it
wouldn't when we tried to restrain it
a little bit better but we knew that it
was a risk that it might so that's
something we noticed
that's on there as well there's a couple
other little things that we've been
taking a look at
but i think you're in general right that
the the actual descent and landing
system behaves as expected
and it did what it had to do especially
given
and a big shout out to the terrain
relative navigation system which put us
down
in the safest spot that was available to
us the places that we had to choose from
weren't great if we didn't have
something like tree and ulta navigation
so
uh yeah the landing system worked great
great thanks al and up next we have
marcia dunn from the associated press
yes hi um wonderful video i'm just
wondering did the jpl
team get to see snippets coming down in
the video
and then or did you have to wait until
this one minute
video was put together what was the
reaction when you
saw first saw the video and laid eyes on
it and
and for david um why do you think the
mic didn't work during defense thank you
i could say a couple words about the um
the first part
i had trouble leaving this mission
support area this week just because
i kept waiting for every little bit of
information to come back from uh
particularly from these cameras but from
the vehicle in general
and i can tell you every time we got
something
people were overjoyed
giddy they were like kids you know in a
candy store
uh you know we get a little we get a
thumbnail which literally is just a
really low res
blobby looking thing of of one of those
videos
that came down first and we'd just be
falling on the floor
excited with what we were seeing and
that's before even the high-res
came you know there's a lot of people
that have contributed to uh to this uh
entry descent and landing system
our uh our chief engineer adam stelzner
happens to be here
in the uh the studio he was kind of the
father of the sky crane system this
started 15 years ago for him
he and his team have never seen this
system operate before not even on the
earth because we can't test it on the
earth
so this is the first time we've had a
chance as engineers to actually see what
we designed
and uh i just can't it's hard for me to
express just how emotional it was and
how exciting it was for everybody
as we got this information down i'll
turn it over to dave to say a couple
words
before you said that can i just chime in
on the the first image of this justin
i will say um when when we get these
first image
any of these imaging systems the test
images never look as good as the real
thing it's not even close
in fact it's very hard to simulate a lot
of these things especially these
you know sky cranes and things and so
the images that we normally see during
test programs are you know there's
always like a ladder in the background
or the lighting's ever quite right or
there's a car
in the case of the edl cams where these
big targets out in parking lots and
we were dodging cars to try to do our
tests and things and so
that moment that you get these images
from mars it's it's just kind of an
electric
feeling where it just all just snaps
into place and you get these pictures
that are just like
perfectly you know they're pictures of
mars that you can never simulate here on
earth
and i think that we all experience that
especially after you
we go through months and months of
testing and the images
don't really look that great and you
know people get skeptical like are these
these cameras really that great because
you know that looks like a garage or
something uh so
we're it's just amazing to get these
pictures and i just i think we all feel
that way because we're all
seeing pictures of insides of labs and
everything and they're never that great
that uh it's amazing to get these photos
from mars
okay i'll give you my take so uh
thursday evening and friday
when the data started to come down and
we kind of realized what we had i was
sitting at home and my phone started to
go off and i was getting face times from
people who were in the msa and what was
happening was that they were starting to
show them on the monitors that we have
hanging on the wall
and people were turning their phones
around and saying girl you got to see
this reaction and people were just
jumping up and down and giddy and
ecstatic and it
it was a great feeling i mean from where
i was sitting i only was excited to see
these videos and we had captured
it was also the fact that a lot of
people had put a lot of effort in to
make this system
work and to actually reward that effort
and to
to pay it back and and get this
excitement going
it made me super happy i was glad to see
that all the hard work all the
dedication had come in and that everyone
was just
excited about uh not only what we
captured but
also what this mission um could do going
for forwards
it was a great feeling it was a feeling
i won't i won't forget for for quite
some time
and then regarding the question about
the microphone we started to look at it
what we think happened is that there was
a communication error
between the device that is responsible
for
digitizing the analog signals that the
microphone picked up and then passing
that
to the uh the computer that actually
stores all the data
we're not exactly sure why it could have
been a fact it was just so much data
coming into the system we tested it but
you know obviously everything's a little
bit different on mars than we actually
have here
here on the ground so we were pretty
quickly able to determine
didn't think there was a hardware issue
with the microphone which is why we were
able to uh
approach the product and get their
concurrence to try to turn the
microphone on then on that saw
to boundary it's just unfortunate that
that error happened during the edl
and and we just weren't able to record
any of the data that uh that we
generated uh during the sequence
all right thanks and up next we have
chris davenport from the washington
post hi uh thanks for taking the time
and for showing this i really appreciate
it um
i wonder if you could talk a little bit
about the cameras that were used to
record the video
i understand they were specially
designed maybe a commercial company
called
fl ir systems just curious to know
like what goes into you know designing a
camera to sustain the the g's the blast
of the thrusters
everything that it's got to go through
to capture that images
uh thanks okay so the cameras were
originally purchased
from a company called uh point grey
which was then bought out by flir
and i can tell you that modifications we
made to the camera
were minimal this was not a camera
specifically designed for use on mars
you can purchase the same camera off the
internet for whatever applications you
might have for it
the only things we did is we actually uh
added some bonding material on the
inside
to try to make sure that uh in the
dynamic environment of launch
and then that mortar fire event that we
talked about uh that the camera will
continue to operate
and then we had to swap out a couple
pieces on the inside because
in the vacuum of space they had the
ability to outgas
material and if that material deposited
itself on the detector then we wouldn't
get
the clear images that we actually got
but other than that
it was not specially designed for use
for this application it is a commercial
off-the-shelf camera
thank you and up next we have michael
sheets
from cnc
hi congratulations again on capturing uh
stunning footage of this landing i'm
curious on two aspects i mean one
adam seltzer you know you guys had said
that in 15 years since he
really engineered the sky crane you've
never actually seen an operation
i'm curious what adam thinks about
seeing this
uh work on a planet and secondarily um
how this informs and how it's being able
to actually see the landing
and forms future missions even as
nasa looks to one day land astronauts
you know what does this really teach you
about trying to get people on the
surface of mars
uh well let's see adam's not up here but
i can uh i can channel him for for just
a moment perhaps
and and tell you that uh you know this
is a throw of a lifetime
i think not just for adam but all the
people that
contributed uh to to this architecture
development
uh back on curiosity i remember
when we first briefed this uh
this this system you know with the
supersonic parachutes and uh
you know multi-body systems and we're
gonna lower this thing on a tether and
people
just looked at us like we were insane
you know
and uh adam uh and his team
of which al was part you know they kept
at it and they explained why it made
sense they explained why it was robust
they explained why it would work it was
not easy to build i will tell you that
as as the flight system manager on
curiosity but
once you build it and once you test it
it's something uh that really
is designed inherently to interact with
the uncertainties that
throw at you throws at you and uh
and so i think uh being able to see his
system
operate like this you know in high
definition
landing at jezreel you know it doesn't
get too much better than that i don't
think
so i'm going to throw it to al you can
maybe say a few words about the types of
technologies and
and information that we have on the
technologies on the system and
information we got getting back from
edl and we'll be getting back as part of
our reconstruction activity
that feed into the future yeah i mean i
think we can talk about a lot of things
i mean
but as matt as matt mentioned you know
as a fresh-faced kid uh
when this guy was invented and i was in
that room and uh
it's amazing to see it finally in action
even though we knew it worked once
we didn't know for sure it was going to
work again and then for it to work again
and then
for us to see it is incredible and just
starting with skycrane there you can see
some things that i think are going to be
useful to the future
one thing that's of course of a lot of
interest especially as we start landing
bigger things is the plume ground
interaction
the interaction between those rockets
and what they're doing to the ground and
how they kick things around
and we've got great video of that here
this time both from the rover download
camera and the descent stage down the
camera we can see how those uh how they
create those scours and stuff gets
pushed together and creates a sheet
underneath the rover
we can see that all occurring so that's
super useful
the parachute stuff too one thing we
didn't show necessarily here is that
that
the parachute upload cameras the two
that we got are at 75 frames per second
so we can see the inflation that only
occurs in you know 0.7 seconds in less
than a second
and see that snap open and look at all
the details of how it unfolds and
and how it's symmetrically inflated and
all those things are very useful
for future missions uh both whether
they're landing more things in people
or stuff and then people you know sll
other missions are going to use future
missions like the sample retrieval
missions
are likely going to use things like
parachutes and rockets of course
so we're very interested in seeing how
uh how those
those cameras and what we see in the in
that in those camera images can teach us
about how those systems are actually
performing
and make our systems more robust in the
future
thanks alan matt up next we have ken
chang from the new york times
hi thank you um i wanted to give me a
few more details about
how the data came back there's 30
gigabytes that was collected
how much has come back and what was the
data rate that you were able to send
information back thank you maybe jessica
can uh
so i can say that as part of our
commission activity we actually walk
the data rate up uh over the course of
our different overflights with the
orbiters
and so we start with
uh to ver
a lower rate um 2000 8000 and then we mo
we increase that into an adaptive data
rate with the orbiter in which we
can continue to go many uh megabits um
i'm sorry two meg
eight uh meg and then uh much further
beyond that
um over the course the total volume that
i don't have off the top of my head and
so maybe i don't know if that's
something that dave or
we can provide for you later
justin do you have how many how many
images we got back yeah
so we counted yesterday that we're
releasing today there was a
about 4500 that we've gotten so far that
we're pushing out to the web today
um and i will mention that when the
orbiters fly overhead
the compasses typically return let's say
500
to 900 megabits per pass
and we've had i don't know well we've
had a lot of them now like five or
ten of them we've typically had two to
three
over flights per night and it does vary
the rates i was remember
the communication rates from the rover
to the orbiter and then once that's
collected
then we're anywhere from you know some
passes
smaller 80 uh to 100 and where we've had
other passes
uh which have been significant amounts
of data up at 700
and so it is variable per orbiter and
per orientation
yeah and i would add one more thing i
wanted to mention about the the camera
technology and then this data
we haven't mentioned it but in addition
to use commercial cameras um
we're using a commercial computer an
intel based
pc that's running linux open source so
it's the first open source at least that
i know of
open source linux box running on the
surface of mars especially inside the
rover it's
quite compact and so there's the linux
operating system
and we compress the video using ffmpeg
which is another open source tool so
thank you to the open source community
for allowing us to use your amazing
software
appreciate it i just uh just
very briefly i just want to note as
jessica said
you saw some of the terrific imagery
from the mars reconnaissance orbiter
we've been getting fantastic support
from the orbiter community
not just mro for for both that imagery
and the comms
but also from maven which is a goddard
space
spacecraft from odyssey one of our older
orbiters
uh in isa european trace gas orbiter as
well some of the biggest
data volume passes we've had brought
back a lot of this imagery
came from our partners in europe and so
thank you all to them
okay and up next on the phone lines is
mike wahl
from space.com
thank you all for doing this and yeah
yeah it's really amazing video thanks
for sharing it um
just yeah there's a question for for
dave um
what do you anticipate doing maybe with
with the edl mic now that it's up and
running do you see it having any kind of
diagnostic uses during the deployments
of the robotic arm and sort of like like
the instrument checkouts and so forth
um yeah i mean what do you see it doing
aside from recording martian wind and
the sound of the dirt under the wheels
and so on
thank you yes we've had a lot of
discussion about how we might be able to
use
both the edl cam microphone and the
super cam microphone to do those type of
diagnostic
stuff i mean the ops team right now i
don't want spooky jessica but they're
focused on getting the system deployed
and capturing noise of that is
definitely not the first priority they
need to focus on getting this vehicle
ready to perform some amazing science
but that doesn't mean in the future we
could not sit down and discuss the
possibility of capturing
audio files of an actuator as it
actually uh
spins on the surface of mars um you know
that the noise is an incredible thing
that engineers can use to basically
detect the health of of moving systems
gears and actuators and things like that
and so
if we get a snapshot of of uh actuator
today
and uh you know you can compare over
time to another snapshot another audio
file of that
of that actuator in the future compare
the two and see if there's anything that
can be learned in terms of the health of
that
that device now with that said i do need
to remind everybody that uh
the the microphone that's in the edl
camera system just like all of the
the cameras and other hardware is off
the shelf hardware it is not designed
to live in the hostile environment of
mars it gets down
120 degrees plus below zero at night and
then it warms up significantly more in
the data
what minus 40 or something like that so
those temperature cycles and that cold
temperature are going to
significantly limit the life of of these
devices they're just not designed to
last for long periods of time the
supercam microphone might continue to
work it actually is designed a little
bit more
for this particular environment it can
last longer so i think
you know as you heard i think dr z
mentioned earlier we're always surprised
by
how rugged and robust some of our items
are how long they actually last
you know they they continue to operate
far longer than we designed them
we've gotten pretty lucky over the last
couple of days perhaps we'll get lucky
and the hardware will continue to
operate uh
on the surface of mars and allow us to
do those type of diagnostic things in
the future
i don't know jeff you want to add
anything more about how you might
consider using them
well i can i can say that that
application was one of the things that
we had projected
and tested and wanted to make sure that
even though this was
a capability that was part of the cruise
and entry descent landing software
package that we're operating right now
we've also carried that capability
forward into our surface software
and so um assuming the hardware is good
we uh we're
open and ready to use it yeah and i will
mention
um to the question we we actually have
gotten requests from instrument teams
wanting to turn on the microphone to
observe their instrument functioning uh
moxie is one of the instruments that's
going to be generating oxygen has
compressors and scroll pumps and things
and they actually want to want us to use
the microphones to do diagnostic
acoustic measurements so i actually
think that this might become something
that
all rovers might want because everybody
knows that when you hear something
squeaking it's diagnostic maybe you need
to
check it out and it tells you a little
bit about how it works
and so we will find out how these get
used it's actually kind of exciting
and we're getting requests from the
teams so we're gonna and we're working
to
put those into the plan i'll just
say i hope it does survive long enough
so that we can hear those wheels
crunch over the surface of the planet
because i think we would hear it
and i think it'd be great to hear that
big rotary percussive
jackhammer drill taking that first
sample
uh of a rock on on mars as well i think
we'd hear that also
so i'm hopeful that that our our little
microphone will hang in there
for some of those events
okay and up next is lisa grossman from
science news
hi thanks for taking my question um the
video is amazing and a lot of it looks a
lot like the
um animations that you've shown before
the landing to to kind of advertise this
excuse me going forward how will you
distinguish the video
that is the real video from the
animations to kind of make it
clear to people what they're looking at
and keep them from getting confused or
not be fuel for conspiracy theorists
saying we haven't actually done this
i guess i could try to take that one i
mean i think we should label
very clearly which ones are from mars
and uh and not
uh i think it's cleared a lot of us but
i think you're right right given the way
that
the animation's been pretty good uh you
getting a good sense for
uh for how that could be confusing i
think we should label them going forward
now that we have this kind of
you know we should be clear about what's
uh what's real
what a great problem to have exactly i
mean it's an amazing problem
justin do you have anything uh anything
any thoughts here
yeah i i can attest to it's real it's
actually real i know
because i know the data very well it's
it's stunning and it's real and
that was our thought too when we first
saw it we're like wow this looks
like doesn't look real um but it is and
that's what's so amazing about it and um
you know i i know i've seen some of the
video games are getting pretty good you
know
second glance you look at a sports game
and it looks like it's real but it's
fake but this
is actually real stuff and that's why
it's so exciting
um and i actually just want to say uh
for those of you that
watch the videos personally i like
watching like quarter
quarter speed or even slower because
there's so much detail in there
that anyone who's done animations know
that knows that that would take a lot of
time to do
and it all happened so quickly and the
camera cut everything and so that's how
that's how we know it's real because we
we know so much about these these
systems but
there's just so much detail um that
that's
that's one way that you could you could
look at um but yeah
there's one other thing i forgot too i
remember early on msl when they started
coming up with the animation for
uh for curiosity's landing uh we had a
discussion about the uh the plumes
actually coming out of this end stage
uh and the fact that uh that they were
clear and that you wouldn't see them
uh in real life like you can do you
don't see them in the rover upload
camera
but we thought that it would be that
people would be expecting to see them in
the
in the animation so they took some
artistic license and putting them there
so here i can tell you now that
hopefully our future animations will uh
we'll show the right thing and show the
the clear plumes like you see in the
real video
yeah the same comment for the exquisite
detail on the rover if you actually look
at you know every cal target's in place
every little
twist in every tie cable tie they're all
there in the animations you don't have
that when you get down to that level of
detail
at least at least now you you know
typically don't because a lot of the
things happen
kind of last minute and you know the
rover's getting built and people slap
things on and they're not in the drawing
so the animators don't pick it up
and that's another thing that's amazing
about this video every single detail is
in there so
encourage people to look at it it's fun
thanks justin it really is some
beautiful detail now we have
a social media question to take jerome
on twitter asks
some pictures we can see dirt and small
rocks inside the real
wheel rim was this expected and will it
become an issue if more dust and sand is
picked up along the way yep i can
i can speak to that so uh it's not
uncommon for us to have
uh rocks and dirt inside the wheels um
at
either from the landing event or as
we're driving
across the surface you'll also notice on
the deck
we also experienced some of that debris
coming down
on top of the rover and we design our
mechanisms for these conditions
so we don't expect any issue with the
material from the landing event or as we
continue to surf the
rove across the surface
thanks jessica and right now we have a
call from
eric berger on ars technica
yes hi thank you very much for doing
this congratulations on such a stunning
um array of photos and and videos um
alan
chen or al chen mentioned the dust
earlier and i
it was striking as the spacecraft got
close to the surface how much was kicked
up
um it's a one-ton rover it's pretty
sizable but you know when you're talking
about human missions
um it's it's much larger and so you know
what does
you know what does being able to see
this dust tell us about the challenge of
landing future
kind of much larger spacecraft on mars
is that something
that you're going to have to account for
and if you know
is it going to be a really significant
issue to deal with thank you
yeah i think i take that one i mean i
think you know as most people know right
there
as far as i'm aware there are no landing
pads on uh on mars or barges that we can
land on
uh prepared places so we we're gonna
have to deal with especially if we use
repulsion where we have to deal with
uh this plume ground interruption and
it's really difficult it's difficult to
get right
to get the modeling right to get uh to
understand it or even to do a real test
that does
that shows a good impression of what
you're going to come down on especially
when you don't know exactly where you're
going and what the terrain is like
and what the ground properties are where
you're coming down so i do think this is
a big challenge
for us going forward and that's why
collecting this information here is
useful
we can certainly begin to see how it
actually behaved in real life and see
how things
begin to move and what those scours are
like and we have a vehicle that'll tell
us what the ground that we happen to
land on was like
and we know how we were commanding those
uh those engines and where they were
pointed
so we have a rich treasure trove here of
that we can use to kind of
get at that kind of challenge but
because i do think it's a big one
especially as we start to land heavier
and heavier things
with bigger and bigger engines
and up next on the phone lines is joey
roulette
from the verge hey
uh thanks for doing this um earlier it
was mentioned that scientists are
already uh pouring through the thousands
and thousands of images and
i was just wondering what about um the
surface or the rocks that you guys have
seen so far from these images
are standing out uh and kind of what has
been
interesting from a scientific
perspective thanks
ken ken's there yeah okay ken
sure uh so uh you can go online and
see that image uh that was put up uh
during my
little bit there but um we're noticing
basically the different
colors that we see and and textures and
tones and
and so one thing that's striking to me
standing out to me
some of us is that um a lot of the the
rocks that are labeled
as light rocks uh seem to have a rough
texture
uh whereas some of the darker rocks
further afield that that are
higher standing more like large boulders
um seem to be smoother um
that can mean something about the the
grain size and the
and the potentially the composition uh
of the rocks themselves
one of the things where we're noting um
as the resolution gets better
is that these these light rocks uh
closer to the foreground may actually be
kind of dark
on the inside and that the light tone we
see may be largely due to dust covering
and where the rocks stand up a bit
higher and have less dust
they tend to appear dark so a lot of you
know new patterns are emerging
and then of course one of the most
exciting and interesting things are
these
what we call the holy rocks uh that are
you know in some cases right under our
wheels and these smaller cobbles
that are right around the rover um
i didn't mention uh but you know one of
the possibilities for those holes
is that they are what we would call
vesicles which would be
uh due to gas escape from a volcanic
rock
we're not calling them vehicles at this
point because we it's important for us
to stay open
to the you know different possible
interpretations
and not get locked yet on limited data
but if they are volcanic that is is
enormously important
uh to us because it potentially provides
an opportunity to get a
a really nice radiometric age or an
absolute
date uh if a sample like that comes back
to earth
but then again if you go back to to
images from many
previous mars missions rovers and
otherwise
you'll see that that wind abrasion can
cause those
those sorts of holes in all different
types of rocks
uh so just a few of the thoughts that
are that are emerging and then
of course we're starting to get views of
the delta front now which just
have us you know on cloud nine uh
looking at some of the targets further
afield that we're excited to explore
great thanks ken we have another phone
line question mark castro from
astronomy magazine hi
thanks for taking my question um i guess
this is a question for al
and i was just wondering if you could
speak to
the performance of the landing vision
system if you've gotten a chance to dive
into that how
uh the range figure and terrain relative
navigation really
performed and just sort of what it was
thinking how it was making its decisions
as it descended uh and then when you
look at its performance and its accuracy
you know how do you judge it
and can you see that improvement over
curiosity
yeah that'd be great i mean i'm i was
really hoping for a chance to speak that
a little bit actually uh the lander's
vision system as part of the train
relative navigation system
really did great um in fact you know
here's some stats right the
uh based on the targeted well we took
many images on the way down
uh we got tons of landmarks where we're
real very able to match up what we saw
with our onboard map
was almost perfect better than many of
our field tests or even simulations
so we got a very good good lock on where
we were
and in fact when you combine that with
our safe target selection and where we
flew to
we only missed the targeted pixel by by
about five meters
so we were aiming for a particular spot
on the planet once it decided what was
reachable and what the safest spot was
um and given the uh given how well the
lander vision system performed
and our system in flying is there we
only missed by five meters
so that was really great i mean i think
the uh we've really showed that this
system can do what we
what we wanted it to do in helping us
figure out where to go and go to a safe
spot
great thanks al we have so many
questions coming in that we are going to
keep the phone lines open for a little
while longer
to press star one to get in our queue
for now i'm going to take a social media
question
from bob on twitter who asks how does
the processing power of the onboard
computer
compare to a great smartphone matt do
you want to
take that one yeah sure that's that's a
good question you know
in the space business um we have to
build things that we know uh are gonna
are gonna work
and space is a pretty hostile
environment and the surface of mars is
even worse with the temperature swings
which we were talking about
you know you need systems that are
capable of
of dealing with the radiation and and
the temperatures
and and really perform with very high
reliability so as a result of that
we have a tendency to use systems that
have been around for a while the
well shaken out uh and on
uh on perseverance we're using the same
computer
that we used on on curiosity in large
part because we know it worked and we
wanted to have that successful flight
heritage
uh that we had from from the previous
mission so this is a computer that uh
you know
you would have found 15 or maybe even 20
years ago
that were were flying having said that
these edl cameras which we were just
talking about are off the shelf
you know state-of-the-art new technology
and uh it is always a thrill for us when
we have the opportunity like we did in
this particular application
uh to bring that kind of technology into
our systems
uh it's a very powerful way to multiply
our
our
uh our functionality and our capability
and uh and so this was a great example
of being able to use
um new technology uh so
uh so i don't know if that's an exact
answer to the question
but uh in short that's uh you know
that's uh that's a summary great thank
you matt
and thomas uh we actually have a
question for you coming in
hayden an 11 year old from ireland on
twitter
asks what advice would you give to a
budding planetary scientist
in working towards maybe being part of
the mission that will bring
back samples to earth in the future
well i'm so glad for that question i
think about that a lot and the advice
would i would give
is first of all that's exactly the right
time to get into that career
braden that that now that could not be a
better time to join that career or even
if you
started 10 years earlier or you know in
10 years now is the time
to start that the advice i would give is
uh look uh
go really start playing with data right
away
kind of i mean yes go to school you know
the teachers that are there are your
allies going forward you know to
eventually
probably open you perhaps at the
university or at an advanced school but
go to school do that but the other thing
i want to just uh give you advice on
hating this is you know we're putting
all these data
out be your own researcher learn how to
do that
kind of go play with it that's what
research is so much about and find
others who are just excited as excited
as you are
and i'm sure soon enough we'll have you
on our teams
in uh in the future that's some great
advice thank you thomas
and up next we have on the phone lines
alexandra witts from
nature magazine great thanks very much
i'm not quite sure who to address this
to
but i wanted to ask about insight and
whether insight had heard perseverance
lending
so i'm not sure anybody up here has the
latest information have do you al have
you heard anything new
just heard from other folks on the team
i'm not sure this is official or not but
that they
hadn't seen much yet i think we'd have
to check uh
to be honest to be sure we got the right
answer so
great thank you and then another phone
line question from
jackie goddard from the times of london
hello congratulations everyone one of
the most common questions that i get
from
readers who aren't generally a
scientific audience but
regular folks is what is the point
of spending all this money to go to
another planet and explore it
and sometimes that's not even a question
it's a statement there are cynics out
there
can you say why we explore and how does
humanity benefit
from you finding out what you find out
and doing what you do
thank you
[Music]
yeah why don't i why don't i get started
turn it over to you matt is that okay if
i start math you're good with that yeah
yeah so
frankly i'm thinking about this question
all the time
uh why do we explore and of course when
we do that at nasa i just wanna
just let everybody know that if you look
at
how much money we're spending on each
planet and the exploration of each
planet of course the majority
uh kind of that the money where the
planet we're spending most money on
of course is the earth the place where
we live for our friends live for our
history is
and we're so where our future is going
to be and so we're not confused about
the importance and
just as excited about the the amazing
future of what exploration
is uh going forward exploration for us
though is broader than just
what is useful right now and and the
reason we're so convinced that that is
important is first of all
uh the questions that have driven
humanity important questions truly
historic questions
in so many ways are what we're really
about addressing those is what we're
really about as humans we want to be
sure
you know as we look at our contributions
of our generations that we
really move forward uh what we know and
how also
uh really affect how we think about
ourselves and that so often comes
through our research there's a second
reason though
it's truly secondary but i'm going to
mention it anyway
so often and surprisingly
the results and the technologies that
we're building
for the very questions that are really
driven by
fundamental science questions are
extremely
useful and i just want to remind you
that perhaps today
whoever asked that question is driving
around in a car with a gps system built
for an entirely different purpose and
looked at the weather forecast
with the port was not anticipated when
in fact uh we built
the first earth satellite so yes we want
to
uh kind of focus on the immediate needs
today and it's really important but it's
so critical for us
as a species to look forward and explore
matthew thanks thomas i i think you said
it
really well you know i've been landing
things on mars now for
25 plus years and so i've had a chance
to go out and
and talk to a lot of different people
and it's it's not unusual when
somebody asks this question and and i
used to
you know have a long list of of reasons
uh
and there are a good long list of
reasons um but but fundamentally
i've come to the conclusion that in some
ways it's kind of a
moot question um because how can we not
explore
it's just who we are it's what we are
it's in our dna
you know you almost you couldn't stop us
as a species
from exploring i don't think i think
it's part of the reason why we're
you know at the top of the food chain is
because we're curious
because we want to go to places we
haven't been
we want to answer questions we don't
know the answer to
sometimes we want to find the questions
we don't even know need to be asked
you know it's just it's just part of
part of who we are
and and it opens new
horizons new frontiers it
inspires us um it inspires kids
uh you know and as as thomas mentioned
all the academic programs that that are
paying attention here
uh science to technology
that that we bring to the table that
that's important for us
uh you know and uh i think that's the
best i can do to answer that question
there's a lot of reasons
all right we can move on now to another
call
from matt kaplan from planetary radio
hi everyone congratulations uh from
not just me but all of the planetary
society
i've been texting with uh our boss uh
bill nye the science guy who has been
watching
uh everything along with us and uh
here's part of his reaction oh my this
is astonishing
astonishing dare mighty things
but here's my question for ken wilford
uh ken
getting these first images and video
from so much closer to the surface of
mars
than we have from the orbiters in spite
of the great job that they're capable of
does this start to make you think about
the potential
of doing this on a regular basis from
balloons or
let's say a helicopter
well sure you know almost everything i'm
thinking about right now is potential
um i've uh i guess i've compared it
um you know to several people who have
asked me how i'm feeling
you know what's it like and and the
closest thing i can compare it to
is i would say the birth of my daughter
you know where
uh the the cruise phase that's about
eight months long
you know is like that uh that nine month
period where you're just waiting
and you're just hoping everything goes
right and then and then she's born
uh in this case we're on the surface and
it's real
and the potential is astounding i mean i
was just
uh katie stack and i were just texting
last night as we got some new images
down and and we're just
you know we're so excited like like kids
just looking at every picture and
and seeing so many new things and having
so many new ideas and new questions are
appearing
and and the potential of it all is is
what strikes me
more than anything we have so far to go
so
so much to learn uh and i just couldn't
be more
more grateful uh to have made this
transition from
from all the years of hard work and and
stress and wondering
you know is it going to work out how's
it going to work out to now when
we actually get to do this thing uh it's
just
it's it's amazing
thanks ken and up next we have irene
klotz from
aviation week thanks
uh just looking ahead a bit um what's
been the
probably for jessica have you made any
progress
homing in on a site for the helicopter
flight demos
and if so about how far from the
perseverance landing site are those
so the team has started to evaluate um
and is uh
using the images that we've received
from entry descent landing as well as
now these uh
images that we've acquired over the last
couple saws
we are fortunate to have landed in a
potential
spot for that but the team is still
evaluating
and is looking forward to
additional imaging from the 360 degree
panorama from the
nascam z as well as a
future data that's to come down so we
have not locked in a site yet and that
will still be
work for the team to go looking forward
whether it's here or a few 100 meters
away
and we have a social media question
coming in
jake who is 12 years old on youtube asks
was there one point you thought that
this would be impossible to do
that that's a that's a great question
jake
[Music]
there might have been many points where
it felt a little impossible
i'll just i'll give you my one moment
and then
the other folks may may want to add in
and that's uh
you know last march when the
uh kova pandemic struck you know we just
um we were we just shipped the
spacecraft down to kennedy
dave gruel who believe it or not this
whole edl camera gig
is is is not what he does for a living
he was our assembly test and launch
operations manager
and he along with his deputy art
thompson were responsible for
assembling the flight spacecraft testing
it
and getting it down uh to the launch pad
for for launch that's actually
what he did for a day job so uh so the
pandemic struck about a year ago and
dave and i
and art and others were just constantly
on the phone trying to figure out how to
react to it and how to respond to it you
know we
um i said it before we didn't have a lot
of margin we didn't have a lot of time
um you know we were we were figuring out
a lot of things as quickly
as we could and our focus was shifted
from
trying to get the spacecraft built and
tested correctly and staying on schedule
for the launch
because if you miss it you gotta wait
two years for these planetary launches
to mars
um and suddenly our whole focus had to
change to keeping the people safe and
keeping their family safe as a number
one priority
and i wasn't sure honestly i wasn't sure
we could do that
i knew that if we couldn't keep them
just as safe as they would be at home
doing other things that you know that
that could be
that could be it for us for this uh for
this opportunity
we got tremendous support across the
board from the institution
uh here at jpl from headquarters thomas
and
and smd uh and we got through it
but um that was the existential moment
for me
uh that that very uh that
that time right there the first three to
six weeks
um after after code would really hit
hard
so anybody else same answer
yeah exactly same answers okay
i'll add to that um one of the things
about
that's interesting about this this these
jobs we have
are we spend years i mean seven or eight
years for me
and all these guys we years and years
years of work
building testing making sure it's gonna
work
and you know i have to say there's some
amount of stress
involved when you spend seven years of
your career doing something and
then it all comes down to like one
moment and for me it's obviously like
those first images that come from the
cameras
like you really want that to work like
really really want it to work and you've
tried everything you can do to make sure
to work
and so um but you know it it's
definitely
you know we're we all we try to be
open-minded about what could go wrong
uh we try to cover cover all our bases
and um
and that's what's one of the great
things about jpl is that there's a
team of people here really smart people
you go to these reviews
uh to review your product and your your
designs
um we call them withering reviews you
get you get a lot of tough questions
um but that's one of the really you know
jpl is a real gem of the place because
we built this culture of always
questioning
what could go wrong but hoping for the
best and and it's a really
interesting experience i think we all
share that
i will agree i think we invite the
feedback from
each other and our reviewers to make
sure that we are
thinking about all the things that we
need to think about and pushing
ourselves to
meet those challenges and uh and of
course you want it all to work but
um you know there are some things that
you know
you worry that you didn't think about um
but as a community and as a collective
and as
you know a team you know we use each
other to help
make sure that we're covering those
bases
i think the team really did persevere
and we are here today
uh up next is leo enright from irish
television
thanks very much raquel uh i i just
realized
there's no doubt about it 12 year olds
definitely ask
the best questions but if you'll forgive
me for
um going geeky on this could somebody
talk to the traversibility of
canyon duchess now that you've seen
these amazing pictures
do you think that you can just simply
turn around the rover and head directly
west northwest
possibly right past the descent stage
or realistically are you going to have
to go to the northeast
um around olympic
and then to uh chiamanfoya
i'm sorry for being geeky but it's kind
of
a serious question can you move quickly
so i can uh i'll comment and i'll let
ken comment also
uh you know we have uh spent
you know as we do in our development
program as we were mentioning you know
a lot of time in different conditions to
evaluate the performance of our system
and one of the things that we did on
this mission compared to other missions
was to enhance
that traversability capability with
enhanced autonomous navigation
and as well as processing while we're
driving so to increase our drive rates
now we have many more images
and still to assess in terms
of evaluating our path forward
but i will let ken speak to maybe some
of the
areas that we are interested in pursuing
and what's really great is that we work
together
you know with the science and
engineering team to evaluate
those paths and what sort of
terrain is the best for our system
yeah so it's a great question and it's
it's our major focus right now on the
science team is
is answering exactly that question uh
what are we going to do what do we want
to do
uh where do we want to go uh and i'll
say first of all we're
so extraordinarily happy about exactly
where we've put down
because we ended up right on this major
geologic feature this contact we call it
between two two differently mapped
units and so you see there's this sort
of uh
undulating feature uh that
you know this sort of obvious line um
that we're landed right next to and
that's the big contact one of the major
features we were hoping to explore
in this mission and it it uh presents
for us uh one of the big mysteries uh i
mentioned the you know the possible
vesicles
uh it gets down to one of the big
questions for us early on is what
is that crater floor uh made of
and are there igneous rocks there
sedimentary rocks both
uh you know there's a lot of
implications for both so
so what i would say we're probably
currently leaning toward is is exploring
that contact which would not lead us
more
i think to the second um of the two
options but we'll see we
we've got a good amount of time while
the team
does the commissioning and checks all
the systems out and during that time
we'll be
digesting all those new images and doing
a lot of strategic planning
evaluating different options um arguing
amongst ourselves
in the team right after this this uh
press conference is over
our first science team meeting uh post
landing starts immediately after that so
we'll
we'll start talking about just those
things so we'll see
thank you jessica and ken uh up next we
have stephen gorman from
reuters news hi thank you very much can
you hear me okay
yes we can yeah so my question is i have
like a question about the superlatives
regarding the video footage of the edl
sequence
and the audio of that gust of wind that
was picked up on the martian service by
the by the microsoft so i believe
is it correct to say this this video
marks the first
sort of moving footage of a spacecraft
from a spacecraft from that sphincter uh
showing it's it's
it's uh descent and and landing on the
surface of another world
you know mars or any world i think right
i would be that
including the moon or an asteroid or
anything and then secondly is this
likewise is this the first sound
recording ever made on mars
or any celestial object on earth or just
the first one that was made that's been
played back on earth i don't know if you
could
just uh clarify that
i can um let's see on your on your first
question
uh putting aside the apollo program and
the moon and just talking about planets
uh this is most certainly
i'm pretty sure as far as i know this is
the first time we're able to see
ourselves
see our spacecraft land on another
planet
and uh and hopefully that that answers
uh the question that you you asked
as far as sound i'm not sure anybody
else has any more information but again
as to the best of my knowledge this is
the first
planetary sound that's been recorded
so yeah go ahead justin i can i can
i can add to that uh in terms of sound
the the
um the insight lander has a seismometer
on it and they did measure
uh seismic signals that were
acoustically driven and then rendered
that as as audio so that that could be
potentially another another one but um
in terms of like
imaging and doing video um msl did have
a descent imager that did video
uh three and a half frames per second so
it was a little slower
and that was the marty instrument we've
also done time lapse
of deployments of things on inside you
know we deployed a seismometer and we do
time lapse
video mars pathfinder we did time lapse
video
of the rover driving down onto the
surface
uh but then again it was it's time lapse
you know so seconds in between frames
so it you know it's you you've probably
seen this they're all out on the
internet the the
rover movies um i worked on that as a
postdoc
actually but this is definitely the best
video
of any of them so i think we can at
least say that pretty definitively it's
it's just
it's a whole nother level of of
capabilities that we now have so
great well that is all the time we have
for questions today
thank you so much to our panelists we
unfortunately can't answer all the media
questions on there
for those with additional questions
please call jpl's
digital news and media office our social
media team
will continue to answer questions online
and we have
a reddit ama with perseverance team
members
starting at 1pm pacific time today
now to see the raw images of mars visit